welcome to this video playing net roast
not trust whatever 2000 from the United
States we're going to play a close
Sicilian I have played this guy once
before with the draw so let's see what
happens here seems that he's going for
who Bishop age six at some point I see
Sir doing that well I can I can't castle
even it's not a big deal especially
considering that he's played a form oh
wow quick F form okay with a four it's
pretty clear that he won't term that you
won't cancel long anymore so I can also
take him
yeah Bishop g4 also good maybe Bishop g4
okay maybe I can get in b5 try to at
least I'm trying to prove that the
Knights here are good the bishop on g2
is not not a very dangerous piece at the
moment
okay yeah that's interesting this
transformation I wasn't sure at the
moment here before Sam saving the night
the nidus is nice looking on d4 but this
is so this is the typical Anna
Kournikova phenomenal phenomenal is this
the right word it looks good on d4 but
it does not win anything yeah I know I
borrowed this from from poker where ice
king is the Anna Kournikova end but
sometimes it's the same a chance you
have a piece that looks nice but it
doesn't do anything or at least there is
a problem at least okay i managed to at
least to not lose the night but i could
put it put it down on d6 ok he might
play here but I have some counter play
against c3 md4 i'm going to take once
play you for maybe I'm okay yes III is
really a weakness hmm what is he doing
there's some sacrifice I don't know
rookie five or something no
I be here in like an hour will be too
it's never an idea hmm if you for no
I could good plane I'd be 54 just
getting on this pawn
does not feel right in a way I don't
know some of my pieces don't coordinate
well but maybe I'm wrong
thomas III how would I see keep it
as I see no no great reply
now I King look somewhat shaky and yes I
don't see a way at the moment how he can
enter my position like Queen to e7 and
starter Star Trek style would be winning
be mid to e7 but I don't see ok he's
trying to to do it do it with G form
okay I guess I'll shoot I should take
him
okay so look a three I guess who it
feels dangerous maybe I'm overcautious
but it feels dangerous Queen twin be too
maybe 94 queen bee seven King age 6 okay
so who interesting very interesting way
to play but if i take it
but I can check it and play 96 maybe we
take it 96 keep it keep b7 protected
now he can he can know the the night is
super super defender it at the moment
keeps everything covered f seven ng some
time warning ah why didn't I go out with
the king my this wasn't i wasn't really
necessary I could have also just played
this this more actively check check
yeah I need to change the leap on
check
I can go to f6 am I didn't do it but if
would have been interesting though check
no time check check
check and a draw but not with this time
unfortunately being drawn oh you agree
to that that's nice does not happen very
often okay wow this was tough I mean I
around here i think i should i should
yeah i should i should somehow win the
thing but i didn't I played some some
weird moves some bad moves let's go back
here around here should summer win an ID
for I have this active move but okay I
don't believe that this is really bad
went here here check it took check check
and here of course not back to e7 I need
to go to g5 I overlooked Roxy 67 this is
now very good I my king is not under
fire d3 is hanging if we look at this
for example yeah this is this is just
very active like it's a porn app this is
a rock on d6 and I have the upon its
minus two points something by the engine
yeah at least minus two this is what I
what I must do and then I'm okay around
here I thought that white should have at
least a good counter play now this is
given as equal by the engine yeah it's
always very difficult to evaluate what
what does equal exactly mean it gives
them it gives us some sort of Perpetual
here be shown here that's it's it's very
difficult to play with the with the pin
group the eight this is the line that
the computer is giving check with the
draw
the perpetual year only three yeah very
hard to hard to judge in a practical
game anything can happen okay thanks for
watching